[Music]  well hello there and welcome the  drewbermers show family is so happy to  be back at it for season two now with a  chance to host a live audience in this  little studio we call home here in new  york city thinking about how exciting it  will be to meet people visiting from  towns all over got me reflecting on home  towns and that special pride that we  have  where we're from so let's start a  movement show us your hometown spirit by  using our hashtag drew's hometown spirit  to share what you love most about your  neighborhood and tune in for our special  two week long season premiere starting  september 13th to celebrate hometown  spirit with us kicking it off in my old  hometown of los angeles who knows maybe  we'll feature you and your city on the  show